[Music]
so machine intelligence includes two
main areas one is high performance
computing all the chips you need to do
the complex math required and then
artificial intelligence within
artificial intelligence
all the breakthroughs are happening in
the area of machine learning and machine
learning includes the ability for
computers to think learn and act on
their own there are a lot of great
examples throughout business government
and the nonprofit world as well for
example in the US government machine
learning is completely changing how
census workers visit houses to collect
the census data these numerators in the
past would just use their own judgment
on what Ralph's to take and when to
visit houses and of course they often
found people not home in the upcoming
2020 defending census machine learning
will actually give them the best route
and the best predicted times to find
when people are going to be home when
people ask me if machine intelligence
will affect them I turn the question
back around and say could you imagine
your life or your job without the
internet and most people will say no and
I say that's how machine intelligence
will become for us it's already involved
in our personal lives whether it's
Amazon recommendation engines or Netflix
recommendations but it will continue to
spread not only in our personal and
entertainment lives but also in our
day-to-day work lives as well one
example is IT departments in
corporations many companies spend the
majority of their IT budget on IT
operations operations and maintenance
and it's a huge budget line item machine
intelligence is now able to perform most
or all of those mundane routine
activities
that frees up an entire skilled
workforce to focus on creativity and
innovation beyond the jobs that they're
doing today so machine intelligence is
not about completely removing the person
from the equation it's about machines
and humans working together we never
recommend that you completely abandon
your judgment as a leader many times
machine learning is wrong and as leaders
we need to recognize that and know when
to ask questions and how to adapt so
judgment is still absolutely critical in
this equation an interesting example is
automated trucking company auto it was
formed by Google engineers and within 10
months bought by uber for six hundred
and eighty million dollars now what
would make a company worth six hundred
and eighty million dollars in ten months
well auto develops a cab top device
sells for $30,000 and can fully automate
any 18-wheeler truck built after 2013 in
fact they've already made their first
delivery using a self-driving truck it
was fifty thousand cans of Budweiser
beer last year right now the truck can't
handle every situation it's really great
on the highways but it has problems in
bad weather and on city streets so for
now the drivers continue to ride in the
cab but when they're on the highway the
driver is free to conduct whatever
activities they choose and I love the
story of a driver doing yoga while going
down the highway and then the driver
takes over in difficult situations there
is no question that artificial
intelligence will replace certain types
of tasks there are tasks today that
machines are better at than people tasks
like organizing remembering finding
patterns so those kind of tasks will be
replaced by machines but people are
still so much better at creativity and
framing problems and reasoning so what
will happen is that machines will
replace the wrote some of the wrote
tasks that people are doing today and
it's up to us and to figure out as
leaders what do we do with that talent
and how do we take advantage of the
opportunity that that gives us so it's
not a matter of machines putting people
out of work across the board what goes
hand-in-hand with that are the new
businesses that it will create the new
industries that it might spawn and a
whole new set of demands that aren't
that don't exist today that people will
be able to go into for a second or third
career one example of this is the data
Science Bowl every year we put on the
data Science Bowl with Kaggle and we
choose a really hard social good problem
kaggle puts it out to its community of a
million data scientists around the world
and they saw they work as volunteers to
solve the problem last year the
challenge was around heart health and
this year it was around new ways of
predicting lung cancer and of the top
ten winning teams many of them had no
background in the medical field of
whatsoever prior to this competition
they were able to learn what the medical
knowledge they needed through tutorials
and because it came at it from different
angles and different perspectives they
were able to make breakthroughs in the
lung cancer challenge the top ten
algorithms will improve by 10 percent
the accuracy of predicting lung cancer
in fact one of the winning teams has
already secured venture capital funding
to turn that algorithm into a new
business so that's an example of a
business that didn't exist previously
and is launched because of machine
intelligence as a society meaning
to make sure we help folks whose jobs
will be taken over by AI because there
will certainly be tasks that are no law
that no longer require a person to do
them the answer to that dilemma is to
retrain those folks into different skill
sets that can be applied to the new
industries and the new companies and the
new jobs that are created so the best
policy position that we can take as a
nation is to invest in retraining those
workers it doesn't help to deny the
problem or to think that it's way out
when it's already happening today we
need to be proactive about retraining
that workforce so that we don't have a
class of people left behind and by the
way this doesn't apply only to
blue-collar type jobs for example
doctors their jobs will be completely
disrupted and changed will no longer
rely on a doctor's knowledge or
experience to diagnose and treat
diseases instead doctors would become
interpreters of models the legal
profession will be disrupted no longer
well we require people to do research on
precedents and case law machines will be
able to do that so it affects every walk
of life and every industry but we need
to invest in the people who are
displaced so that we take full advantage
of that talent to use toward greater
ends one thing I say about barriers is
that anyone can learn machine
intelligence many people feel like this
is something they had to major in in
school or they have to work at a tech
company to become an expert that's no
longer true many of the leaders that we
interviewed for our book have no
background in machine intelligence
whatsoever
before they took on these projects and
so anyone can and should learn about
machine intelligence it will be that
much of a game-changer
[Music]
you